gary you talk straight
how are you feeling after last night did
the best team win
best team won uh if we look at it just
purely on football absolutely they
played a really good game in italy after
a difficult start the game they
they got on top they controlled the game
demonstrated authority in the class that
they have they've obviously got a
fantastic goalkeeper they've got a
defense that's
resilient and they've got a an unbeaten
record now which i think stretches back
some 30 odd matches so look in the end
we just couldn't go that sort of extra
and go over that extra hurdle but how do
i feel this morning
i feel i feel quite good um in the sense
of
as an england fan and watching the
players and thinking about how they've
handled this tournament good about our
manager good about the way in which the
players conducted themselves the way it
wished to perform
you know gareth and the players found a
way to get to that final last night
i know people will say that maybe we
could have been this or we could have
been that could be more attacking could
have made that substitution all those
things that were here but they got
it so right during this tournament that
i trusted them to the end and they just
fell
short uh but proud proud of the players
proud of everything that they've
achieved uh i feel connected to them
i've not always felt connected to
england teams as a fan growing up and
even as sometimes a player and as a
coach but i felt connected to this team
because i felt as though they did
everything in a way in which to be fair
you should they carried themselves
brilliantly on and off the pitch
and they played really well uh
you've been there you've suffered this
kind of defeat and disappointment with
england yourself as a player
give us an insight into how that team
will be feeling this morning especially
those three young players i mean
the youngest sucker just 19 missing
those
penalty spot kicks how will they be
feeling this morning and what will gary
southgate
be doing to look after them honestly
there'll be none some of them obviously
the ones who may be feeling a little bit
more than the others the ones who maybe
miss the penalty or not they'll be sad
but they'll want to go away with the
families they want to take some time off
they need a mental and physical break
that'll be there for
their first thought how quickly can they
get on a plane and get somewhere whereby
they can just relax and reset
and think about starting again in a few
weeks time but obviously as well they'll
have that many words sort of coming
at them they'll just want silence i
always wanted when i went out of a
tournament i just always wanted to get
away as quickly as possible really
and just to be on my own with the family
not talking about football just getting
back to normality because they've been
in a bubble for the last five six
seven weeks not been able to see the
families not being able to
obviously mix with anybody they'll have
been in that hotel room
and they'll just want basically
normality back in their lives for a few
weeks they've done it
incredibly well the spotlight and
scrutiny has been on them
um and they've been heavily praised for
everything that they've done in this
last few weeks but they'll just want
some peace and quiet in their lives this
morning if it was like
you know when i got knocked out of the
tournament but they should also be
incredibly proud of everything that
and everything that they've achieved as
well because they've done they've done
something no england team has done for
55 years that's reaching a final i know
it's not enough
because we had to win to really take it
that step further but it's still
brilliant what they've achieved in the
in these last few weeks
gary you do hope that the players do
switch off in a sense because
if some of them look at social media
this morning
it will make for awful reading
a number of the players coming in for
racist abuse from
so-called fans in particular those
young players marcus rashford sancho and
sacca
coming in for racist abuse for simply
missing a spot kick which many england
players up and down the years have done
what's your reaction to that racism
rears its head
time and time again in football and now
we see it when england have performed
the best they've ever done since 66.
well i'm just reading you breaking news
it says the pm condemns racist abuse of
england players
is that the same prime minister that a
few weeks ago i mean
gary southgate in the players a few
weeks ago about five days on the trot
told us that they were taking the knee
to promote equality and it was against
racism
the prime minister said that it was okay
for the population of this country
to boo those players who are trying to
promote equality and defend against
racism
it starts at the very top and so for me
i was i wasn't surprised in the
slightest that i woke up this morning to
those headlines i expected it the minute
that the three players that missed
missed
and you know the fact of the matter is
there is an issue obviously in football
there is an issue in society
where we feel it's acceptable basically
to criticize
players for sporting actions because of
the colour of the skin
but i have to say you know
accepting and validating that players
who take the knee like i say were
promoting equality inclusion
and defending against racism is coming
from the very top
and you know you know full well that if
your parents do something your children
will follow
and i'm not saying that each individual
person who is uh
who has obviously directed that abuse
towards the players shouldn't take
accountability they absolutely should
social the social media companies
you know we know full well now it's a
well stole well told story that the
social media companies have to come down
harder
on racist abuse i think we have to start
to isolate these individuals who are
attacking the players
in a racist manner and isolate them by
writing to their employers
so that ultimately there is total
accountability and there is suffering
and consequence
but also that to be fair there is
consequence within the game through the
fa the premier league and other
organizations uefa and fifa
and we start to see you know sentences
and
and punishments for these incidents that
ultimately fit the crime
because people are being abused it's
absolutely ridiculous in 2021 we're
still talking about this but we are
yet gary a lot of people saying in this
tournament that a lot of political
figures
could take a leaf out of gareth
southgate's book when it comes to
leadership
and as you mentioned there his stand on
diversity
and inclusion do you think the prime
minister needs to take a look at gareth
southgate
and do more in this area
he said muslim women look like
letterboxes
i think he does yeah do you know should
we not be highlighting this
more often i mean honestly gareth
southgate and boris johnson there
absolutely
poles apart well as a gentleman you can
be a leader
and a gentleman you can be ruthless but
have empathy and compassion i mean if
you look at boris johnson every time he
speaks and this is not conservative this
is nothing to do with tory party labour
party liberal democrats
i really am disenfranchised and
disconnected from what i see in politics
at this moment in time there is a lack
of leadership
gareth over this last few weeks as every
time that he's come on whether he's won
whether he's lost whether he's talking
about an incident
like racism he talks with dignity it's
genuine
it's compassionate it connects to the
people of this country
it's someone that i feel i can connect
to and feel like i know
and yet when i hear sometimes you know
that the mp speak i'm like
what what is happening here how can we
vote for these people look at him
you know he's hooking the captain of
he's hooking the captain of the
opposition team one minute and he's
hugging saka the next minute with
compassion
and that's what a great leader has done
and gary southgate over this last three
to four years not just three to four
years throughout his life actually
has carried himself brilliantly as an
individual and it demonstrates that you
can be a gentleman you can have really
good standards
but you can also lead
gary i know you feel very passionate
about that what's
next for this england team it's the
world cup next year
can we go one better
geosomething after last tournament i i
said i hope these lads get the
opportunity to experience
the semi-final opportunity again to get
to a final
they actually got there and in the back
of mind i always worried that that might
be the best chance against croatia in
russia
in 2018 but they've got there again they
proved us all wrong again
in the sense of what england teams can
do because i always think you get to a
semi-final then you can gary we're
running out of time
but i think yes they can we'll see you
soon